una albergue temporal en Panamá con más
de mil venezolanos son los rostros de
los que han tenido que renunciar al
sueño americano están a la espera de
retornar a su país sima un poco tristeza
pero lo que pasa es que quiero estar con
mi familia quiero volverme porque si no
Cumplí mi sueño realidad ya me toca irme
cuando mi familia porque
aquí han tratado un poquitico como más
la embajada venezolana está organizando
viajes voluntarios de regreso lo deben
financiar los propios viajeros con
costes que llegan a los 280 dólares
estamos pasando mal pero como yo mira
con dos niños mi esposa ellos son cuatro
pasajes a 280 dólares Quién va a poder
pagarle ese hermano casi mil y pico de
dólares yo no puedo pagar eso tras
cruzar el mortal tapón del Darién muchos
quieren volver a casa esto después de
que Estados Unidos anunciase que
deportaría a México a los migrantes
venezolanos que se han detenidos en la
frontera solo habrá 24.000 visas por vía
aérea los que se marchan quieren evitar
llegar a la situación de sus
compatriotas variados en la frontera
entre México y Estados Unidos muchos
están durmiendo en la calle con
temperaturas que bajan hasta los 4
grados centígrados
aguantando usted era como tú y yo esa
luz no sabemos A qué tanto lleguemos
entre octubre de 2021 y agosto pasado
más de 150.000 migrantes de Venezuela
fueron detenidos en la frontera Sur
estadounidense tres veces más que en el
período anterior